[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
you know what today on the show uh we're
talking snyder verse
we got a little andorra
news ethan hawk did an interesting
interview and most importantly we're
going to merge the world
of great batman films and musicals
welcome to the break room hey
welcome uh breakers roomies the
br heads uh
tea in the chat if you're a trash panda
or a teepee um i'm i'm joined on the
break room from live from the new
rockstars offices in california we've
got brandon barrick oh hello thank you
for your service okay we've got jessica
clemons hi
and as always uh
mr tommy bechtold
hello all of the energy oh
um this is of course the the nerdy show
that um keeps you up to date on all the
latest breaking happenings for the the
ip the content that we love oh did you
know that the break room's on tick-tock
um you can follow us on tick-tock at the
underscore break room uh tommy's been
putting up some really fun content on
there yeah we've got some stuff cooking
today even and we we even got a few
drafts you might be sharing and there's
rumor of a studio tour
so yeah you know this studio yeah no
don't show them all i'm gonna show the
full address
um and hey if you want to be a part of
this show you want your voice to be
heard on this show not in some kind of
metaphorical like go to the ballot box
kind of way i mean your literal voice
you can leave us a voice message on the
new rock store new rock stars discord um
which is open to the public anybody can
join that you leave a voice message
there i think you know what i would the
voice messages i would love to hear this
week before friday put in your most
specific comic-con prediction oh yeah
then next week we might listen to some
on-air we'll either roast you for being
really wrong or will give you credit for
nailing it we'll test you we'll roast or
toast
uh whoever's got the most there might be
room for a boost you know i'm taking a
look at papa jakey's uh comment that was
58 eggplants that we planned for review
i think we let that one fly next time
guys
i think this show is eggplant friendly
full of antioxidants
and uh finally before we get to today's
headlines we've got a very special chat
redemption we want to tell you about uh
as always anytime we hit a multiple of a
hundred dollars in super chats which
we're so appreciative of everybody who
throws just a couple of doubloons there
um it triggers something happens on the
show today in honor of today is philip
molina's birthday
today
yeah
wait a minute happy birthday philip
molina yes uh which everybody that
follows him on any social media platform
should be we got so many
blocked in the chat right now uh but uh
speaking of eggplants uh everybody
should tweet at phillip a happy birthday
today tell him the break room sent you
yes um he he loves to hear from folks
that enjoys work or that care about him
so do that in honor of him for our chat
redemption today every time we hit 100
bucks
uh jessica
is going to like at a children's
birthday party
paint one of our faces yes
but she only has 30 seconds to do it i
only have 30 seconds to do it can i get
camera for real quick
guys normally i i yell at you i admonish
you
uh today i'm begging you it's philip's
birthday and he watches these super
chats if we don't raise enough money
he's going to shut the break room down
and he's going to you know break one of
our arms or something
in honor of philip we ask you to give
generously for every one of these
eggplants you put in give in five bucks
okay
for chrissy's sake i see poor chrissy
just trying her best
mafia so give generously you absolute
pieces of garbage also jake hodge
discovered uh uh eggplants are getting
filtered bananas can slip right through
that's
if
right
follow phillip on twitter you better uh
send him a tweet say happy birthday tell
him the break room sent you tell him
we're the only show on the channel
promoting his birthday right let him
know let him know we sent you to say
happy birthday uh and someone in the
chatbot and i missed their their name
it's also benedict cumberbatch's
birthday oh
i've never seen phillip and benedict
cumberbatch in the same room they can't
they can't have depending on how he
styles it they can kind of have similar
facial hair um happy birthday philip now
let's get to today's headline
yes
um the first headline and maybe the
juice yesterday there was this bombshell
rolling stone article that came out uh
it was released it spilled all kinds of
tea about warner brothers dc and kind of
all of the snyder cut fallout uh allison
crooks thank you for your generous um uh
free yes now you get free eggplants um
but there was a lot of juicy details in
this rolling stone article we want to
break down a couple of them yeah first
off it came out i never i hadn't heard
this before warner brothers wanted to
replace henry cavill and ben affleck
uh as batman and superman immediately
after justice they had to have been
behind the scenes base because i thought
henry k i personally enjoy henry cavill
as superman and i thought ben affleck
didn't find him well in the batman the
robert pattinson batman was originally
slated to be a batfleck player right
yeah wasn't he gonna write it yeah he
was either gonna write it or direct it
or he was going to play both batman and
the joker
yesterday and we've heard we've never
we've never heard either way about henry
cavill there's no more plans for him to
appear superman but they're also not
recasting anybody
well it does feel like after the kind of
lukewarm reception of batman versus
superman they were like after this
justice league let's let's let's shake
it up um but wait there's more okay um
supposedly zack snyder demanded uh that
two producers names were removed from
the credits of the snyder cut jeff johns
and john berg if you've been following
this kind of tabloidy saga behind the
scenes there's a lot going on between
those two producers
zack snyder
joss whedon ray fisher a lot of stuff
going on but apparently zack snyder
specifically blamed those two producers
for him kind of losing control of the dc
universe and then
we've we've talked about this for a few
days uh oh thank you alice uh wishing
happy birthday to phillip um the head of
uh
q5id
which is a company i hadn't heard of but
apparently they specialize in
authenticating like identities online uh
was quoted in this article as saying
that uh there's no questions that bots
were involved
and the whole hashtag released the
snyder cut movement
and now there's been some speculation in
this article
that zack snyder himself
was a part of the bot
army movement oh boy
what say you
tommy have you ever utilized a bot army
no no no not on twitter but uh
my medical history has been no secret on
this show and it takes a robot army to
keep me fit as to kill all the animals
that's right first of all i utilize
robot hunting elimination machines as
you said i also utilize robot groomers i
mean i'm being groomed 24 7. i have
manscapes just tinkering away at my
you know my my uh my forest my glaciers
my foggy mountains high
uh my home's deep if you will okay all
being uh all being escaped by robots so
thank you to my bots
i have lots of thoughts about bots but
that's for later release all i know is i
i'm more uh uh skeptical of these bots
being involved with the oscar
yes yeah the two the two justice league
moments i got in those oscar categories
very high up on the list one of them
tapping the list yeah although that that
i'm a little suspicious of those and a
big behind the scenes here at new
rockstars right like we are very online
so like very online movements like
release the snyder cut right intersect
with us our hosts a lot right eric was
kind of like on the wrong side of the
release the snyder cut folks for a
little while and like and it's tough
both from our perspective from anybody's
perspective to identify like well how
much of this is a true fan groundswell
like there's a lot of enthusiasm versus
like how much this might be manufactured
or being manipulated by people behind
the scenes and i think like
who knows how accurate some of the stuff
in this article is but like it's an
interesting take on that right
yeah um anyways moving on uh oh we got a
new and or tv spot yeah not a lot of new
footage but it was a it was a fun little
clip tommy it had more and or than the
first spot despite being uh twice as uh
short however i will say you know
obviously i've you know i've been
studying up on andor i'm excited about
it it's coming soon i know that we
haven't necessarily had the fervor
there's some other star wars projects
yet but i think this is going to be such
an interesting opportunity to explore
the rebellion from maybe a slightly more
brutal
side than just you know i i was joking
earlier calling a new hope like like
rebellion university like luke went off
to college and was like i'm gonna be a
star fighter now we're getting a chance
to see like who's down there in the suck
you know as they say like these are the
trenches
welcome to the stock
i just think it's gonna be
you know it's gonna be a slightly more
gritty
uh not necessarily like a gritty reboot
but we're going to see the uglier side
of rebellions you know both sides
argument maybe the emperor
wasn't all wrong yeah yeah that's what
i'm saying this show is going to finally
show us why the rebellion was a problem
no the empire was right oh no uh and the
rebellion should be destroyed and wiped
out completely i agree with most of the
time brandon
all right
oh hot takes high takes here on a
tuesday um uh next headline sony uh some
sad news maybe for folks who are eagerly
anticipating this film sony is pushing
madame webb
the upcoming spider-verse kind of uh
film from july uh of next year to
october of next year so just you know a
four-month delay
i think this movie doesn't make it out
in 2023
i agree i completely i know i know and i
maybe my mind's a little uh you know
from the recent going through the
pandemic things getting pushed like
every couple months it would get pushed
again but this already early push i'm
like i don't know i feel like they might
sit on this one again when they kept
morbius on the shelf for like two years
but that was totally pandemic related
can i can i say one thing yeah the in
defense of madame webb
for once on this show
uh adam scott is a true nerd he is a
true aficionado of comic books and nerd
culture
i don't think he would make his like
debut into this foray in something that
wasn't at least had the potential to be
better than we all think it's sure sure
or
uh he wants a a new boat yeah
he wants a pool uh no problem with
either of those answers that's fine
who's getting their face painted by the
way whoa
we have um can we do a quick poll
uh in the chat to uh pick which one of
us also we're well on our way to comic
con on monday yes oh we forgot to
mention
we're doing these week-long redemptions
if we hit a thousand dollars for the
week right um next week monday's episode
will be comic-con and i want to remember
we have previously announced the
celebration of jessica clemons a
three-minute celebration and brandon
will have a four minute whatever he
wants to do as part of his winning
mandatory fun yesterday so we've already
got some things announced also i'm
working on an exclusive that i think you
guys are really going to love
so if if you want to see that on monday
comic-con um there won't be anything
else to talk about on monday so we can
spend most of the episodes i'm talking
about
also if you raise two thousand dollars
i'll never appear on the show again oh
there's uh there's stay money and then
there's go away
okay i'm like adam scott i can be bought
that's right
uh and then uh our final headline here
um ethan hawk did an interview um where
he was talking about he was kind of
weighing in he was asked about the whole
like our marvel movie cinema that whole
kind of stale debate that um uh martin
scorsese and francis ford coppola kicked
off by insulting our favorite mcu films
um
and he kind of played a little bit of
both sides where he was like well
they're not wrong
and one thing he kind of pointed out is
like you know marvel is
has been has developed this reputation
of being very actor friendly not
necessarily director friendly yeah these
two guys are directors so maybe they're
purely thinking about it from that point
of view um ethan hawke has done
directing and obviously a lot of acting
so maybe he's kind of seeing both parts
of it and he specifically quoted this
like he referenced the relationship
between kevin feige and robert downey jr
as being like a very collaborative
creative process where um robert downey
jr was able to kind of spearhead his
character
and like how cool that is for an actor
to be able to take that ownership over
something where where do you stand on
the actor friendly versus director
friendly
when i read the article it started to
make sense because the actors still have
within a box to play so it's like you
can't go further than this but if you're
the director you can go as far as you
want so i could see kevin feige being
like because all their directors are so
creative that they will just take the
reins and go crazy with it while i was
at actor it's like you are stuck in this
character you can only go so far so
creatively so it's just like you can go
crazy but directors are like hey
be cautious i have to interject here
real quick zach you've won the facebook
oh my god and what that means to me is i
can take over the headlines something
that they never allow paint his face and
i'm going to read the next headline
please we need to time her yeah
30 seconds 30 seconds
can you turn it towards me do you know
what you're getting 30 seconds
oh yeah
that's great um yeah and just don't
start the timer
until brush hits face that's when the
timer starts let me get the timer
prepared
to skin is when we begin closer to me
i'm sorry all all right and then
all right i'm ready when you are okay
okay i think i just had a look really
quick
pin to pour oh my god okay and the pores
yeah
okay iron heart began filming anthony
ramos of hamilton fame and in the
heights said on instagram live says we
started shooting marvel
s word fire right here you can say
we raised a few money [ __ ] fire he
called it [ __ ] yesterday was my first
day it went well [ __ ] about to be crazy
oh i got to be in charge of the prom
oh boy oh boy you're going the wrong way
sorry still not comfortable
a little confirmation about what
character ramos will be playing
now could he be playing the character
[ __ ] fire oh stop moving your eyebrows
wait wait wait wait give her we'll give
her 30 more seconds well no these are
the rules no wait a minute that's not
fair he moved his eyebrows and started
talking it's like the home run derby if
he does something spectacular we give
him a bonus time is that how it works in
baseball yeah you're saying there's no
integrity in baseball yeah i'm saying
they're yeah well yes we do we already
knew that
let's go so anthony ramos i am excited
about him joining ironheart he is a
great actor he's amazing in the heist
i'm excited about anything with
ironheart let's go i loved miss marvel
i'm ready for these i didn't these
younger stories in marvel i want to see
what's next for the iron era you know
we're going to have like armor wars okay
you've gone another 30 seconds of this
we have yeah have integrity here can we
get a face reveal
can we get a reveal
can you guess what it is does it look
like it it's a mouse with a huge penis
okay so you guys know what it is
what it is
hey let me can i come in
camera four yeah give them camera oh
yeah give them blue that's what they
want get closer to camera three yeah
we can't
we can't
i don't always believe in our
redemptions on this show but today
everything you know what i mean
for the time
that isn't very impressive jessica you
did a great job why are you apologizing
i think you did amazing i've got a court
date right after this yeah it's a good
way to get off the jury due to custody
yeah zack's gonna lose custody of his
children
finally i'm gonna get custody of zack's
children brandon as your lawyer i have
to ask you to stop um
your honor may i approach the branch
hey this old dumbo
hey i
remember every time that uh something
wrong was done because i never forget
okay um
uh serious news okay yeah let's let's
let's pack a dermit up and move on okay
um
we're close to also getting another uh
breaking another 100 i know and then
another precinct i think after they see
these results we're going to
come pretty soon we're going to have a
whole zoo full of uh people up here um
there's an interview with uh the uh
directing team uh that made miss marvel
and they mentioned this hadn't been
formally stated uh but that kamala
khan's uh family was not blipped
um now it wasn't stated either way in
the show but i i like that the detail
behind the scenes that kevin feige
basically told them don't worry about it
do your storytelling thing right like
don't be hungry about it don't worry
about don't be held back by like needing
to accommodate this crazy world because
it's so basic don't worry about it
everyone's asking about the blip who
cares i read that
i read that interview and it was
it's actually kind of scary i don't know
how directors do it getting chosen to
work with kevin feige because they were
like so what happened to the family and
he was like don't worry about it he was
like don't worry about it don't even
think about it he's like don't worry
about anybody else he's like just worry
about the family that's terrible and i
was like oh my god he's gonna get
because he also doesn't want to tell you
twice yeah and he doesn't want you to
mess it up you think you like bump into
my craft services you ask him he's like
they're fine they're fine and then like
later that night he's like oh did i tell
me oh do i gotta write that down
somewhere it's so interesting because
the mom velani makes it sound like he
like they're so close she's like i text
him being like hey let me do this and
he's like no but with other directors
he's like if you talk to me one more
time well i'm gonna take this cap
on like reddit ama from last week you
know because on the red carpet i think
she had said something kind of like i
don't know about calling it 616 or
something yeah if i was like
no all right
well and it could also hint that like
obviously a lot of the posts in game
content
for this face
learn to love it
because this is permanent paint okay um
but like at some point they have to move
on from
end game repercussions right like
maybe not within three years of the
movie coming out but maybe within 10
right they can't keep talking about
thanos in the blip at some point right
um maybe that signals that beginning uh
but uh finally this is actually our
final headline um
she-hulk actress tatanna and mizlani who
we're all big fans of here we're excited
to see her portrayal she did an
interview she talked about uh the main
villain or presumably one of the
villains of that show jamila jamil's
titania which is a great name um
revealed that like you know jamila jamil
is kind of famously very active on um
very vocal on political and social
issues on social media especially and um
she thinks the actress kind of drew from
that
playing her character
so like interesting we know this is a
villain who wears kind of outrageous
outfits but maybe also somehow
influenced by
political activism she could be like
some sort of uh
you know
doing some sort of protest and too
physical of a way maybe that's how she
got in trouble like an eco-terrorist or
something like that oh sure i love it
freeing animals from zoos i mean hey
elephants running free in the street
okay i can't do it as good as brandon
killmonger was a pretty politically good
spokane get your brush is ready because
we crossed over again
i i'm not getting my well i technically
i could get my face painted sorry i saw
that my name was in there and it's
you're not doing it i'm not gonna paint
your face oh no well i was gonna do john
as our fourth if we got a four oh yes
get yes jessica is our artist in
residence today we will we will excuse
her from getting her face painted but
john if if someone votes for jessica you
will be her proxy yes uh and a quick
thank you yeah we've crossed another 100
boundary quick shout out to um i i
apologize i know you're in poland i'm
going to mispronounce your wonderful
polish name we told jurowitz vittold i'm
sorry uh
jones ryan yachts allison crooks weiss
gold tv
this is me maggs fareed javed thank you
all so much and a bunch of other folks
for throwing um some doubloons our way
um jessica is going to chris is saying
paint john's head
do it paint his head his head is it
chris
mild maynard chrissy is uh on one today
thank you
um
and you know you could get i could get a
double you could do the bottom half of
my face that's true we could we could do
a full body if you want but
we could do one of those like body paint
things where we just get you completely
naked my whole face could turn into a
noah's ark uh
type of tree of life at disney world
there's over 400 animals on zach's body
right now uh my my face could turn into
a t-shirt that the the weird lady that
lived down the street from you would
wear at a rain toys cafe um okay i love
the idea of wearing rainforest themed
stuff to the rainforest
i'm a huge rainforest cafe fan i'm a big
rain head that's how they that's how
they know you're a real rain head part
of the forest well uh uh well well
jessica's prepping here a couple uh we
had a couple other chats uh or a couple
other polls in the chat um do you think
we will see arthur harrow in the mcu
again
56 percent of people saying no so it
still leaves 43 saying yes yeah
interesting pretty split even though
pretty dead at the end of it yeah shot
assumed dead yeah that's true that's
true didn't i didn't even the creators
of that show tease like it might be
coming back we don't know if he's that
you didn't see him dying
you saw him get shot point blank um i
don't know another poll do you think
andor will expand the star wars universe
further than kenobi did 77 percent
saying yes i feel like yeah i hear
they're going to tattooing no
if they go to tatooine i'm tattooing wow
we're gonna
see the origin of the vespa biker gang
oh god hanging out
when do they get their own spin-off uh
it's just like happy days but it's
tattooing vespa bikers um and then final
poll here do you think snyder sent the
bots himself and you know what pretty
split 57 saying yes all right i'm going
to start the timer for brandon can we do
one minute yeah one minute time can you
give me one give her all the time she
needs one timer and zach and i will vamp
for one minute we'll go to our corner we
like to call z and t's g and t where we
talk about
uh games of thrones
gameplay man comes out this weekend we
haven't done a lot of talking about the
great very excited quick quick plug we
might talk about a little bit on monday
it depends oh oh first before we even
talk about that
we are going to have live
coverage on the new rockstars channel of
comic con this weekend specifically the
marvel panel marvel's back kevin feige
is going to be on that hall h stage
probably dropping some bombs some big
casting news some release news all kinds
of stuff
we both eric voss is going to do
reactions and breakdowns any trailers
that come out
and tentatively
there's going to be a live break room
episode saturday
immediately during the um marvel panel
now the marvel panel is not going to be
live streamed so we're going to be you
know on twitter uh using our sources
philip molina might be there in person
reporting back to us uh but tune in
live saturday afternoon um for our
coverage of comic con there'll be some
big news
now how much more time do you need just
30 seconds just 30 seconds i'm sorry and
then yes the gray man's coming out uh
this friday all right starring chris
evans and chris evans ryan gosling from
from barbie break room barbie watch
honor de armas res jean paul from
bridgeton wow uh who oh bridgerton is on
that
now i want to point out nothing has been
more hilarious to me than the fact that
ryan gosling has had to do all of this
press with beautiful bleach blonde ken
hair he has not done a single like all
of the netflix like videos of him being
like the grey man comes out he's in full
ken mode and you know i mean he's a good
looking bless his heart so yes i love it
guy hasn't made a movie in four years
and uh he returns to the public uh
looking like it can be your second time
murder
do you need more no no i think i think
it's fine
i was speeding i was speeding first off
so i'm really you're on speed
let's get a review
chrome here sit in my seat for camera
four
yeah
ooh a serpent thank you you got it yeah
it's a little bit uh why so serious yeah
so we'll get back to that later yeah
we'll save that for my performance with
a gorgeous uh wow
good i mean my only critique is
it should have been the other half of
his face yeah i didn't i didn't hit his
face
well we are honoring philip in the best
possible yeah
with these uh with these face paints
let's keep them coming guys we're only
83 dollars away from john or i getting
painted by the end of this thing we
might just be painting everybody we
might be pulling people off the street
and painting them all over the streets
of tarzana where we will we'll have to
move on to other body parts besides the
face yeah um jessica you wanted to talk
a little bit some news came out about
the thor and credit scene yeah so in a
very cute here let me scoot closer to
brandon
give me the camera too so and then turn
your face that way so people can see
in a very cute display brett goldstein
uh our mcu hercules sent his parents to
see thor love and thunder without
telling him about his post-credits scene
it's very sweet his mom is in the
theater watching it texting him live he
keeps being like look up at the screen
stop texting in public yeah don't text
at the moment
and then during the post credit and she
texts him and goes russell crowe's in it
again he's very funny and she's like
he's like look at that fm screen and
then it's revealed that it's her son um
he mentions in an interview
not knowing when he's coming back he
said it was the best three seconds of
his life but he has no idea they won't
let him talk about anything he also
doesn't know anything that's how mcu
works that's how marvel works kevin
feige so in what way can we fit him into
the mcu i think uh there's been too many
times
um that characters show up in
post-credit scenes that we're never
gonna see again uh scorpion
on from homecoming from homecoming uh
uh venom from no way home
are we sure we're never gonna see
scorpion again well we i don't know well
where's the band we don't have anything
and then uh howard the duck and guardian
of the galaxy now now we do have
confirmation right because we've seen
set photos and casting news adam warlock
from guardians of the galaxy volume 2
post credit scene is going to be in
guardians different volume
differently we never
saw the cocoon or whatever right we saw
aisha kind of well so they didn't get
the cocoon
yeah
crazy chris
christie just donated 70 dollars and
said paint jobs
can i whisper can i whisper to tommy
really quick and you kind of mute it
this is great
okay all right um also uh while we were
just chatting uh philip molina is in the
chat yes he's uh currently uh uh
chatting as the new rockstars account
and he's very confused how this is
honoring his birthday yes uh so are we
phillip you know what you're you're a
fun creative guys who are doing it in a
fun creative way and everything i know
about philip is that he loves face
painting he always talks about face
painting he's always bringing up at the
office he's always like why don't we
cover more stuff with face painting it's
all i care about he has he asked me to
do an entire segment just called face
paint watch where i go around the
birthday parties in the park yes and i
see who's getting painted what's what
who's hot at the carnivals is it
spider-man is there a princess is it a
butterfly who's that there was he sent
me to six different sandals resorts
ridiculously was the most popular face
painting
expensive let me tell you the answer it
will surprise you
it will surprise you who is it did we
get the answer
it's just a single maple leaf oh wow are
we sure that was maple leaf so are you
are you panning jack
i think so i think i'm paying okay
john we don't need to do a poll
no need for a poll john
producer john is going to is it easier
for you to go to producer john uh he's
already here he's on the live stream
have him sit down now uh both both john
and tommy have lovely facial hair which
i don't know if that complicates the
plan to paint their faces or not uh
certainly will complicate the cleanup
afterwards let's save them we'll we'll
pick it up here you keep uh jumping in
jessica
yeah but yeah like we've gotten so many
now every marvel film that has come out
has gotten a new character right with a
lot of stunt casting charlize throne
harry styles now brett goldstein right
how many of these are going to end up
being loose threads that never get
called back to anything i mean we assume
if they make another eternals when they
make another eternals uh harry styles
will definitely be involved with that
and i think that's
that's a get for them that they don't
want to lose yeah right that's a good
get well could they could they put harry
styles as uh aries into uh something
else yeah most certainly but i don't
know how yeah it's easiest to do
eternals i know there's some history
with she-hulk but that's a very bad
history
so like i don't think they want to go
down that path i i i would say
due to james gunn kind of saying the
guardians of the galaxy and his
iteration is any we're probably going to
get some more cosmic
titles released soon that will allow
some of these more space and
time-bending
god-like heroes an introduction that
because eternals
it almost seems like those characters
are too fun for an eternal sequel you
know what i mean like the eternals was
kind of a like serious
meditation on life there could be
overwatch
i mean maybe we get news about this at
comic con this weekend about future
plans for mcu films but like i will just
throw this out there and i wasn't the
biggest fan of the eternal film either
but is there potential there for
eternals to be like thor or thor the
dark world yeah whatever comes next
could be the ragnarok i think they've
they've given you the foundation and now
they can have some fun with it and get
it maybe maybe they realize a little
error in their ways maybe we went a
little too seriously
an off-world story where the macguffin
isn't the earth being destroyed but then
being able to take on the fight with the
celestials is much different yeah and
much more open-ended and much more fun
yeah i think i think it would it could
be really yeah really interesting
totally so all right let's let's p pick
your
who is most likely to least likely to
show up charlize their own as uh clea uh
harry styles as aries brett goldstein is
hercules who else do we want to throw
like has to come in right because of
dormammu right you think clea is like
you're guaranteed we're definitely gonna
see her yeah i think you'll definitely
see her for like a doctor strange three
okay most definitely i think they sewed
up
stephen strange and forgive me uh uh
rachel mcadams characters yeah they
sewed up christine right yeah
in theory we have a mordo issue to deal
with
all of that right i buy it and we could
even see you know i don't know what
agatha house of harkness has planned but
like oh
mysteriously
i think of all the things you've listed
the brett goldstein hercules is the
least is the least likely i think they
have the least amount of plan for that
that is also i feel like just like a not
a cop out but it's going to be for uh
taekwondo in his next film yeah i don't
think he's going to show up again soon
but hercules does and intervene with a
lot of people he's basically in the
comics the hulk he has an issue called
incredible hercules um and he's very
angry all the time he works with the
avengers he's in secret wars he's uh
i know he's a secret invasion i know
he's in secret invasion so it's like he
could come in and yes he has that tie to
um to guardians of the galaxy so there's
possibility to put him in but how we see
him right now i think he's just gonna
fight thor constantly like they're just
going to keep going after each other i
realized more than a minute yeah we can
stop now um i realize i don't really
know how it looks this is going to be
her sistine chapel of face paint no it's
not no it's not no it's not yeah it's
not going to get the big uh also when
does this become the be slowly becoming
a clown meme
oh i should have just did a clown face
i wish i would have done better
i should have paid attention
okay you can turn around now all right
here's your job producer john face
reveal look at him you have to go crazy
he's got the whole world
on his head he's got the whole wide
world
on his head he's got the whole world on
his head he's got the whole world on his
head you know what that is i have a
meeting after this with like a friend at
a coffee shop
afterwards you'll be the least weird
person in that coffee shop
put on a beanie you'll be fine i'll be
honest this is more of a dystopian map
than i prefer the water
i said it i acknowledge it's a little
bit of furiosa too you know what it
means she's got the black paint on just
on the forehead i think it looks like
apocalypto little apocalypse apocalypto
you did good there a little uh um i
don't see the house in the vlog
with that yeah happy birthday phillip
molina yeah again yeah and this is all
for you phil
uh
yeah i i agree though i i would flip it
i think i think hercules makes the most
sense i think they'll squeeze him into
something
um but it could be interesting again i
think we're gonna find out a lot this
weekend when we see after this batch of
films we know we're getting what's
coming after that right then we'll know
like oh okay definitely um for getting
another eternals movie we can expect
harry styles to show up um can i talk
about something fortuitous yes and right
after you talk about that yeah things
are gonna get extra weird if you thought
face paint was a little fun and wacky
just wait wait until our next segment
but please i want to talk about
fortuitous instances and that is that i
did not have my face painted before i
had to do this
we want to thank our friends at better
health because certainly i would need a
lot better health if i had a full cat
makeup while i was doing the ad about
therapy i uh as i said yesterday
recently decided to seek out some
therapy after i've had a bit of some
stressful news in my life i'm fine don't
worry don't pry into my personal life
check the tweets it's all subtweeted
there uh but and i need to rethink the
way i cope with things it can't always
be krispy kreme at 2am life is full of
twists and turns and it's important to
show for yourself through it all better
help online therapy will help you assess
your needs and then you can match with
your own therapist licensed professional
therapist that's important don't go see
my guy in a back alley in less than 48
hours and i can confirm that i signed up
myself i got in it took me
you know maybe a few minutes a few solid
minutes of giving real information about
myself and i got a therapist match
within a day i started in stop therapy
so many times in my life you know it's a
traffic jam of therapy for me we're
moving it's the 405 dead stop
crisis comes back in then we move a
little bit again getting back started
with better health was so easy i cannot
recommend it enough if you're struggling
you need to talk to someone there's no
shame in that better health help is a
quick and easy way to try therapy for
the first time or jump back in like me
guys the water's warm and it's not for
any weird reason okay this is not a
crisis line it's not self-help it's
professional therapy done securely
online available to people worldwide you
can log into your account anytime and
send a message to your therapist again
i've done all this and i cannot stress
this enough if i can do it you can do it
okay you can do your schedule your
weekly video or phone sessions you don't
have to be on camera if you don't want
to getting therapy every week is as easy
as a few clicks on your laptop or phone
and thankfully
we have a special offer for our breakers
our roomies get ten percent off your
first month at betterhelp.com
break room that's ten percent off your
first month of online therapy at better
help
dot com slash break room yeah so we
thank a better help for helping uh bring
this show to you certainly if better
help online therapy something you've
been thinking about if you happen to be
thinking about it anyways please use our
promo code it'll save you some money it
helps us bring this show to you thank
you and now uh i can't wait to paint
your face mandatory oh we've got a lot
of money to raise we're ways away from
folks if you want to see this beautiful
mug uh uh painted into what what
jessica's promised you saving the best
painting for tommy's face i believe
[Music]
although that would be fun but not
mandatory fun
yes the segment's so electric we can
only play the graphic once because we're
already behind today
uh just kidding play it twice
now in honor of philip molina turning 28
uh we are doing his favorite thing we're
celebrating um uh what do they call
mashups we're doing mashups
14 years ago today
two twin flames burst down to the box
office scene that's right today is the
anniversary of the release of both the
dark knight and mamma mia
both opening in the same weekend and
that event most certainly set a
collision course for the cape crusader
in the musical theater ever since oh i
think so thank you very much i wrote
that myself it took me an hour and a
half so for mandatory fun we decided to
cause an incursion and rewrite the
lyrics to abba abba abba i think you say
both ways
not that way i'm a real
we decided to cause an incursion and
rewrite the lyrics to abba songs set in
the world of gotham dear god who wants
to
first way okay
i want to go
perfect oh and by the way i should
mention
the winner as voted by the poll will
receive a five-minute
personal slot i think these are more
punishments musical performances
already announced the brandon barrack
soap box the justin clemens tribute to a
goddess uh
and much much more to come all right so
and again just to be clear we've done
songs uh inspired by both the dark
knight
and sung to the tune of abbasan yes
because they both came out the same
weekend we don't know which one philip
saw first for his birthday he maybe did
a double feature
uh paid for one but saw both yes that's
how he did it he didn't want uh nolan
getting his money at all okay so this is
to the tune of take a chance on me no
you may have heard that yeah
uh and this is about uh one of the
villains in the dark knight the joker
himself baby here we go
as you see my face one thought escapes
that it's quite bizarre
how'd i get these scars my father drank
all night it was rather vile grabbed the
closest kitchen knife and he made me
smile
if you're full of fear come on over here
i'll tell you how i got these guys had a
pretty wife but she got in debt oh made
me made a smile with a knife which i now
regret
[Applause]
we can kill the batman oh we can do some
magic dance magic that's it there you go
yes yes
wonderful wonderful okay perfect mine is
give me give me give me a two face to
mess with
give me give me give me a man after
midnight okay
and i can't hit these notes because i'm
not sweet dish i'm not
don't make me sing
but please do give us some more super
chats because i need to paint tommy's
face um batman signal he's a new
district attorney he's the king of his
own he's the reason your officials got
dethroned
rachel dawes is the perfect companion
the assistant to the man but she's been
in love with bruce since they began
there's not a truth out there
got the must play fair
this is the guitar
give me give me give me a two face the
mess with blow up his girlfriend while
he listens away
give me give me give me a two faced a
mess with flippa corn best of luck you
won't see her today
[Music]
i do like that we're carving out a niche
for folks that love mcu in star wars yes
and musical theater yes or specifically
abba
typically two of our highest performing
videos videos in our dc videos now mine
is set to the tune of uh dancing queen
okay okay
all right uh so uh let me just try
[Music]
oh brand new face
brand new voice acting that won't give
us pause to
see that girl
crush that scene dig it new rachel dawn
oh katie holmes seems pretty nice
but we didn't need to see her twice
twice
we needed a fresh face someone to give
it a roll we needed a chillin
bruce was acting like such a jerk
only saw that his plan would work
but rachel showed so much gusto plus the
joker's disgusting now she's tied up
she's tied up so bruce had a choice
he called her to hear that voice oh
now rachel dawes is dead
harvey dent only has half a hat
oh my god
that was rousing tommy that was great
you really belted that oh god that's
funny uh and i apologize everybody i'm
definitely the least musically inclined
of the group a couple people pointed out
even my chair dancing was a painfully
white non-rhythm
just wait till you hear my voice
though luckily uh producer john hooked
me up i think we're going to have a
little musical background right for my
song uh sung to the tune of the title
track
mamma mia
okay here we go this is from the
perspective
of harvey day
okay we all love harvey dent
oh
okay okay
[Music]
[Music]
i've been chased by you since i don't
look at me now
will i ever learn flip of the coin and i
suddenly lose control okay
there's a fire within my soul
just one face and i'm a good guy
[Music]
hey now i'm the district attorney
gary oldman can you face me my my i'm
getting up in your family
okay
here we go
i'll be aggressiveness to catch up with
the bee that was already gone
i'm gonna say this
if we get to 600 we'll paint my face and
we will do it on quarterback
that's wrong i also have an extra song
we will do this another time we have two
songs we will end the show with a
concert
if we get 57 if we can get
framing all of these lyrics and
auctioning them off uh
at a later date i'm dead dude that was
um dark knight holds up 14 years later
still a good watch i think it's on
netflix right now yeah yeah uh why i'm
here as well guys available on dvd
anyway yeah yeah as we discuss uh the
resurrection of the dark knight and
mamma mia uh we should also talk about
the post-credits scene in thor we wanted
to talk about that a little more today
uh and it you know it was revealed that
heimdall's been been chilling up in
valhalla with a bunch of other
asgardians and gods and whatnot enjoying
the rewards of their noble deaths and
that got us thinking about other deaths
in the mcu and how the mcu
deals with death in general wow i'm
sorry
mls beads and um
a couple other folks mr manny's at a a
uh just dropped to combine 90 bucks in
the chat we appreciate you uh jessica if
you want to
you're ready getting prepared for uh uh
t michael bechtold's uh face painting
there tommy uh but go ahead we'll keep
going so yeah we were thinking about
that like the fact that valhalla exists
in the mcu
uh and eric kind of brought this up in
his breakdown of the ending his ending
explained video that valhalla in the
comics uh when they had ragnarok a lot
of those people in valhalla were kind of
like reincarnated into new bodies like
loki was put into the body of a female
things like that happened and you had
this kind of like
memory of your past life but you were
reborn in a different way uh so we were
thinking is that something the mcu could
do could all of these like afterlifes
and these realms which often kind of are
predict are
presented as almost like purgatories
like not the end but just like a place
where you can go hang out right
does that mean that we could see some
characters returned that were previously
killed off and if they did something
that like that would we want to see it
now we don't mean like
captain america or tony you know i think
steve rogers who is unconfirmed dead and
and uh you know tony who's definitely
dead they don't necessarily need to come
back and i think if you're gonna bring
characters like that back it's more fun
to do it as
variants or like from a different
universe so it's like they're they are
the same actor but it's a different
character yeah but if if they were gonna
bring back some characters who would you
like to see them bring back that have
been assumed dead that they may be
killed off early on or they only had
them for one movie because they're like
yeah we don't need this not realizing
they were sitting on a multi-decade
branch and you're saying that like this
is specifically recaronated reincarnated
via valhalla yes it could be valhalla
but it could be are non-asgardians
allowed to go to valhalla i mean i know
jane foster's technically not an
asgardian but she'd kind of taken on the
role of thor that's probably what led
her in yeah i mean one of the things we
talked about on big question this last
week uh when we talk about the afterlife
with jessica was that you know what we
know of valhalla is kind of thor's
apocryphal tales of it we didn't see a
rule book anywhere
and you know a lot of that is probably
like how religion and the afterlife is
dealt with in our world where it's like
you tell these things to kids to make
them live good lives like telling all
the asgardians they need to die in
battle so they can get to valhalla it
means that they'll keep fighting yeah
right
they will look to a battle uh and
they'll be a strong and they'll be brave
and they'll be brave
but that might not necessarily be the
truth yeah because you know odin wasn't
in the middle of a battle when he died
granted he was the king of
the gods right technically jane foster
was not in the middle yeah
uh yeah so i think either through
valhalla or through any afterlife could
we see some reincarnations happen
uh
in the mcu i would like to see it kind
of done in a with a villain which yes
you don't think a villain gets into
heaven but these aren't necessarily
heavens and houses
yeah yeah um do you have a favorite
villain you would like i mean i want
darren cross to come back from the
ant-man franchise
well not only because cory still did
such a good job and really made him
he was developing a yellow jacket yellow
jacket
isn't there there's some i uh
if you're never seen him no no i if
you're afraid of possible leaks possibly
supposedly
corey stole again apologies to anybody's
plug your ears uh cory stole is an actor
in quantum mania oh okay and we don't we
don't know confirm that he's playing uh
darren cross a yellow jacket but
supposedly that actor is in condominium
which why would they
cast the exactly it could be a uh a
prequel it could be a producer john's
swinging in he's got the whole world on
his head deep rumor deeper
you just like an actor you want to give
him like a voice role for a character
that's going to be all cgi but why would
you do that unless maybe they're going
to say darren cross somehow uh though
how did he die did he get shrunken down
to infinity yes we see ant-man get in
his regulator destroy it uh and he kind
of crumples up in a weird way it's not a
quick little thing i think like parts of
his body kind of suck in first and then
we got a reveal for tommy oh my god with
the face paint a lot of color involved i
think he's maybe
okay let's see
camera four
it comes close your eyes oh my god
you're opinion
the second i thought it was marge
simpson it's gentle minion
how'd you say house of a thousand
gorgeous
sid hag
[Laughter]
you do look like bart you do look like a
simpson's character
uh and just a reminder everybody in
hunter phillip molina's birthday yes
happy birthday phillip this is all for
you we're celebrating with the uh uh the
chat redemption of uh somebody gets
their face painted and you know what
we're not that far off from the next
face painting and we're running out of
faces uh well it's almost time for the
concert i can do it i can facebook right
that's right yeah 700 bucks also very
close to tomicon i think at this point
tomicon is a is a foregone conclusion uh
you know what though sometimes around
wednesday people realize they got too
much grub over doordash and they're
gonna tighten their belts
not this week because like i said every
dollar over a thousand i will make
comic-con bigger and better i'm talking
celebrity impersonators actual
celebrities i got a guy named smush
who's the world's best slash
impersonator yes mush is available to
play electric guitar
he's not a little person it's not a joke
on that he's actually seven feet tall
very in demand with love and thunder
being all these guns and roses yeah oh
yeah oh he's booked solid but i have him
in my basement right now and he's going
to do whatever i say if he ever wants to
see his family again it's a tall
basement
7 feet
banana
but
it was eyes closed it looks so scary
frightening
can you imagine if you're in bed one
night and you roll over
and you have to open your eyes and hang
on before real quick
hey babe
are you having trouble sleeping
oh
just give me a minion
just give me he's a one minion man okay
um best three seconds of my life
take a second on that brett goldstein
oh
okay but anyways uh characters would
like to see reincarnated
um yeah though we might maybe confirmed
maybe well and again not to go too far
down the rabbit hole it is just a little
bit of a leak but like if either darren
cross gets trunk it down is in maybe um
some kind of micro verse or something
like that where it becomes modoc somehow
gets unshrunk in full size still modoc
form that'd be kind of cool yeah that's
that's not quite reincarnation but it is
a way to bring somebody back in a new
form right which i like this idea what
if we even got like thanos
reincarnated in a very different form we
have yet to get like
we had you know a female thor but it
wasn't like uh you know thor
reincarnated as a woman right we saw the
phantom copter right yes yeah did you
see it loki uh oh we did oh my i thought
if i get a joke that was like there was
a giant copter but no you were right 100
also thank you for the donation we're
almost there we're eight dollars away
from me face painting my face and an
encore and i mean only for like elena's
sake it would be nice if she could talk
to natasha yeah
i don't like bringing back her back like
i don't know
like a realm i want claw to come back
you want your whistles
or like ulysses claw
who else anyone that uh what about the
guy that turned into toilet soup in
ant-man
oh frank
frank back
somebody's saying i need zola back
that's a good point we've kind of had
him depicted in digital form but not as
an actual person um that'd be cool
because there's not a ton of dead heroes
to bring back right we haven't seen too
many of our heroes die right early on in
battle oh i have
i mean are we incarnated like killmonger
would be very interesting yeah yeah
in a different form yeah a different
actor
[Music]
quicksilver oh yet another quicksilver i
mean they kind of give it to evan peters
at this point i don't think recast
quicksilver yeah
um
uh yeah somebody pointed out we're
almost at 700 which also guarantees zach
will not sing uh
again i thought um which uh let's let's
throw to chad here who would you like to
see possibly recarnate reincarnated in a
different form brought back the same but
new um let's
i love red school red school red skull
that would be cool keith yeah because
he's been suffering over in his as as
the keeper of the soul stone right well
we only saw one area of vormir there
might be a like
on the other hand that's right
that's when they're getting face painted
it's not what you'd expect that wasn't
actually rental car that was a guest who
was painted so well as red oh my god
that's called face paint is taking off
in sandals i do like phillip in the chat
saying he didn't ask for face paint and
said he wanted a knight of tapas we
didn't give him that well you know this
is a little bit like these these are
just shared plates i thought he said he
wanted a night of ha-has
and that's where i thought we delivered
painting we delivered uh let's let's
shout out some of the folks that uh
helped everybody thank you so much for
all your generosity today in the super
chat you've done a great job you've got
some good fray girl our friend fred girl
saying if your pet could be a super pet
what would their name be and what powers
would they have my girlfriend's three
cats would be the invisible cats and i
would never see them again
mine would be like
sir [ __ ] she i hate my cat i love her
to death i love her to death but even
this morning you know what she did she
pulled down my monitor for my computer
she's one of those cats fan cat
i have a little uh pug uh french bulldog
mix and boy she loves to eat her tiny
tummy can't handle it her superpower
should be like what what is it a matter
consuming lad or something like that you
know she should be one of those people
that could be whatever does she get sick
yes because then she could also like
throw up acid oh that's a good yeah
like uh could toad do that or no he
could just
shoot
saying all songs rock thank you mr
mannies uh miss beads of course led us
to do it
um
uh somebody's saying oh i think it was
miss beads again definitely i think
we've met the mutants in the mcu great
idea jessica i think that was called
that before
yesterday yeah
um what does ray mullins have to say
there brandon uh i did that what
character would you like to see enter
the mcu personally i would like to see
the sentry in a fight with the hulk in a
world war hulk movie so many strong
characters like this century uh i mean
we all know who i want in the mcu it's
jubilee baby
hell yeah i want a three movie jubilee
arc uh all three films over three hours
long
i want bishop
ooh i always like to bishop yeah
i always like forge too yeah those
second-tier x-men are among some of my
favorites we've got to see a little bit
of them in uh just like a grass great
deus est machina like you need a weapon
for just here you can build whatever you
want what a fun mutation um weiss gold
gtv just saying yee
uh as jess gets uh has to self paint uh
bless her heart um look in the mirror
there portrait of the artist as a young
woman
beautiful young woman
uh we've got some other emilio gutierrez
i want natasha back like how they did
for the other nat and what if
oh that's a good idea uh emilio uh nomad
monkey um threw in 10 bucks in the super
chat for phillips tapas hmm yes
hi zach we did tell him we'd on cora as
the way out i know you're trying to
avoid this can we all can we do a group
rendition of tommy's song i feel like
you know damn well i want to hear you i
think we all want to hear yours zach but
you know what we'll do we'll be your
backups this time all right yeah okay
broadway revival thank you i think this
is by far one of our best chat
redemption days um thank you to jessica
for doing that thank you excellent
handiwork i think if if the first couple
ones didn't turn out great i don't think
people would have been excited to see
all the others so you did a great job
could we get guillotine in phase four
white gold ttv asking i'm not even
familiar with the guillotine character
i don't know okay
let's put him in it's a deep cut my man
i can only assume he's french and he
chops people's heads off yeah
yeah aristocrat
yeah it's time what is your net worth
it's time for the bourgeois to pay
that's right take them down okay
bishop's mom she's gotta go yeah she's
too wealthy someone take her down
again
tune in the rest of the week we'll be
getting into uh covering all the news of
the day and uh previewing more comic con
stuff if we get any kind of news coming
out ahead of comic con we'll be covering
that and then
live in person here on saturday we'll be
covering the marvel panel and then
monday
we're all but guaranteed for tomicon
comic-con 2022.
so you know what i've been disappointed
before
i've gotten so close only to fall short
so many times in my life i've tried so
hard and got so far and in the end it
doesn't even matter that's too bad why
don't we play us out with zach's banger
of the song
you have the legend
yes here we go
[Music]
so i made up my mind it must come to an
end
gary
look at me now
will i ever learn flip of the corn
and i suddenly lose control
there's a fire within my soul
just one face and i'm a good guy
two faces everyone must die
whoa
gary oldman
why do you chase me
hey now i'm the district attorney
gary oman
can you face me
my my i'm kidnapping your family
bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you